nein ich würde wieder von hinten
erschossen willst du mich verarschen
hätte ich schieß geraden der fliegt
durchweg alte junge wein gleich
jo leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge ersten folge
wir standen direkt diesen fischen basten
getötet jason orange arbeiter hast mit
artikeln
nein ich würde schon direkt zweimal tief
in irgendwelchen speisten jolo in
gorleben schon aufgelegt nicht doch
schon wieder tut hier noch keinen
einzigen gregor bitte alter also max war
gerade viel besser was man zu seiner
verteidigung sagen ich habe heute in
einer runde hatte ich 20 kilo
die jungs hätte ich hatte 3000 das leone
spaß
ich habe noch zwei leben weil ich die
ganze zeit im boden umfrage egal macht
kein spaß kein stress mit referent bei
dir hier trotzdem wird ich will
allerbeste sei wie geht's weiter
wie keiner vor mir war okay man mir
läuft halbwegs alt aber bei all den
anderen rennt irene die gefahr
ok ich hab' mir noch viele leben viel
reden fick alter stört nicht so rum in
knysna weiterläuft willst du mich
verarschen halte ich schieß gerade
fliegt durch um dich fertig
da war ich kaputt zeit und danach mit
der kaputt gestalter wie sommer noch
klar kommen in diesem leben alter wie
soll man noch heuer kommen
nein ich bin so schlecht so dass für die
fände sie leben ja ich habe ich hinter
den einfach mal nichts passiert mit ihm
geht mir ist auch einer jacke alter fick
dich fick dich erstmal limited von der
runde nehmen etwas zu erleben
aber ich muss noch ein bisschen
ranhalten bisschen ranhalten störe die
rampe es geht ab fast alter
alter wissen pfeiler der der 33 fälle
auf mich geschossen um mich defekte
marke fahrer alter läuft überhaupt nicht
bei uns wieso bist du fertig oder nein
altern ein ultra von uns hat er sich
getrennt
da machen wir kurz dieser runde ein
bisschen pro ja diese müsse jetzt ein
bisschen was geben halt ein bisschen
eskalieren eskalieren und krankhafter
kran teilt bisschen okay ich gehe mal
nicht zu dir sonst für designer von uns
tot am anfang
mit windows als das läuft so gar nicht
bei mir schon ein alter okay dafür
selbst sterben hab ich gekühlten einer
erding gekillt
dieser kleine engel leiter blamieren uns
gerade so hart wie soweto online-oli
alte wie dumm war das von mir
puh richtige verein alter jetzt schon
eine pastorin über bei mir bist oder ja
okay jetzt neue damit hat er jetzt
wenigstens mal zwei kinder jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt bin ich mal langsam
trainiere lebe leider ihr seid mit
sicherheit besser hilfe und vicento auf
jeden fall am besten mal eure kinder in
die comments aber eine echte nicht
irgend so eine frei erfundene würde mich
interessieren
also wie gesagt ich habe es einmal
geschafft ein zwölfer stick auf
wandertour auf grund der quatsch model
in london chamber profil das
glaubenkönnen meine freunde
ja man kann man noch glauben kann stress
doch es wirklich worauf alles also ich
hab wirklich winter gelogen haben sollte
dann sollen wir meine eier abfallen
meinetwegen kreiswerke als dicke feier
im haus weihnachtsfeier die ganze
nachbarschaft ist da und dementsprechend
die ganzen kellys oder war schön sehr
schön haupt oder konkret so ein kleiner
junge aus von unserer nachbarschaft bei
der feier bei uns ist er ich hab schon
erzählt und ich bin tot
runde auf wir an bei dem man minecraft
ein bisschen zu helfen wenn mikrofon zu
rufen ist das was du mit neuer
mannschaft in einer liebesbeziehung
okay das hat euch gegeben von dem habe
ich noch für diese runde könnte ich das
grabmal gewinne wie schlecht das system
warnt die ohne sorge gewinnen können
springt ins wasser und schießen fall in
die wand alter wo man mit irgendwas
machen ja machen auf jeden fall einer
geht noch einer geht noch jetzt bitte an
strecke bleibt dran
wie streng jetzt einige versuche alles
zu geben was geht und sehen uns da ist
wieder okay leute hier sind wir zum
dritten mal und ich wurde
zwischenzeitlich aber gekickt und ich
fasse nein solche sich in zuletzt
geplant wir sind in der dritten runde
meinte chamber und wir versuchen jetzt
mal alles zu geben
ein bisschen zu skillen okay ich hab
meine ersten immerhin mal nein was kommt
denn der feier alter.de ex-wolfsburger
burton krassen anders altern ein
richtiges haben alle hektik richtiger
flammen waren die kommentare
nein nein ich komme ich auf mein leben
klar dumme
ich schwöre ich hab schon wieder nur
weil eben was gott komme ich hab einen
satten kittel einen ganzen kellern und
den hab ich dich erwischt alter junge
ist meine schlechteste runde er war
gerade jetzt gerade jetzt als ich so
dringend gebraucht habe und ich treffe
wieder nicht neu und wird wieder von
hinten erschossen
oh mein gott noch ein leben ein hort des
dreckigen casey wenn sie mit ihren
kehlen bekämpfen bist und du wirst bis
kurz vor ihn zu töten und dann kommt
jemand anders an tötete
ich wein gleich so ich kann nämlich auch
ich habe aber der krankhaft ist okay
wenn ihr findet das war richtig schlecht
dann dieses zeigt uns dass wir die
dünnsten sind in dem wir dieses video
zeigt je mehr likes wir haben desto mehr
wenn wir trainieren desto besser wenn du
alle dezember versprochen dass sie
dringend besser werden müssen dann
einmal licon am besten sagt jetzt auch
allen euren opas und omas euro wie
europas das leugnen wenn wir noch okay
also leute ich würde sagen ja wenn man
so besser wollen dann neigt ob hatte
schreibt in die kommentare und wies auf
bleibt dran weil morgen habe ich mir
sagen lassen gibt es ein richtig geilen
wie locker auf meinem channel also dann
haut rein und ein heftiges service von
mir no von mir auch gut so sonst